¿Cómo es posible que compare a los seres humanos con los caballos?”
Los caballos son muy limitados
y cuando llegaron los autos, camiones y tractores,
ya no tuvieron nada más que hacer.
En cambio, las personas son inteligentes; podemos aprender y adaptarnos.
Y en teoría eso significa
que siempre encontraremos algo nuevo que hacer
y que siempre podremos ser relevantes para la economía.
Pero aquí viene la cosa crucial que hay que entender:
las máquinas que amenazarán a los trabajadores en el futuro
no tienen nada que ver con esos autos, camiones y tractores
que desplazaron a los caballos.
El futuro estará lleno de máquinas que piensan, aprenden y se adaptan.
La tecnología por fin está empezando a usurpar
esa capacidad humana fundamental,
la cosa que nos diferencia de los caballos y la única cosa que hasta ahora
nos ha permitido ir por delante del ritmo del progreso
y permanecer relevantes e indispensables para la economía.
Por lo tanto, ¿cuál es la verdadera diferencia
entre la tecnología de hoy en día y la que hemos visto en el pasado?
Yo señalaría tres aspectos fundamentales.
Lo primero es que
hemos visto este proceso continuo de aceleración exponencial.
Sé que todos Uds. conocen la ley de Moore, pero en realidad es mucho más amplia;
en muchos casos abarca, por ejemplo, el software,
las comunicaciones, el ancho de banda y demás.
Pero el aspecto clave que hay que entender
es que esta aceleración ocurre desde hace mucho tiempo.
De hecho, lleva décadas sin parar.
Desde el final de los años 50,
cuando se fabricaron los primeros circuitos integrados,
la potencia de cálculo se ha duplicado 30 veces.
Este es un número extraordinario de veces para duplicar cualquier cantidad
y significa que ahora estamos en un punto
en el que veremos un progreso increíblemente grande
y, por supuesto, las cosas continuarán a acelerarse desde este punto.
Así que mientras esperamos los próximos años y décadas,
creo que veremos cosas para las que no estamos preparados,
cosas que nos dejarán estupefactos.
El segundo aspecto clave es que las máquinas, en un sentido limitado,
están empezando a pensar.
Y no me refiero a inteligencia artificial de nivel humano o de ciencia ficción.
Solo digo que las máquinas y los algoritmos toman decisiones,
resuelven problemas y, lo que es más importante, aprenden.
De hecho, si hay una tecnología que es realmente vital para esto
y que se ha convertido en el motor detrás de esto,
es el aprendizaje automático, que se está transformando
en una tecnología increíblemente potente, perturbadora y expansible.
Uno de los mejores ejemplos que he visto
es lo que hizo la división de Google, DeepMind, con su sistema AlphaGo.
Este es el sistema que fue capaz de ganar al mejor jugador del mundo
en el antiguo juego de go.
Para mí, hay dos cosas que realmente destacan en el juego de go.
Una es que mientras juegas
el número de configuraciones que se pueden dar en el tablero
es prácticamente infinito.
De hecho, hay más posibilidades que átomos en el universo.
Es decir, una computadora nunca ganará en go
usando la técnica que sirvió para ganar en ajedrez
que consistió en usar fuerza bruta
de cálculo.
Se necesita un enfoque más sofisticado
y parecido a la acción de pensar.
La segunda cosa que se destaca es que
si hablas con uno de los jugadores del campeonato de go,
esta persona no es capaz ni siquiera de expresar
en qué está pensando exactamente mientras juega.
A menudo es algo muy intuitivo,
es casi como una sensación acerca del movimiento que debería hacer.
Así que, con estos dos elementos,
diría que jugar a go al nivel de un campeón mundial
debería ser algo a salvo de la automatización
y el hecho de que no lo sea
debería ser una seria advertencia para nosotros.
Y el motivo es que tendemos a dibujar una línea muy clara.
A un lado de la línea ponemos los trabajos y las tareas
que percibimos, de un modo u otro, como rutinarios, repetitivos, predecibles.
Sabemos que estos empleos podrían ser de distintas industrias,
de distintas ocupaciones y niveles de destreza,
pero por ser intrínsecamente predecibles sabemos que quizá algún día
sean compatibles con el aprendizaje automático
y, por ello, con la automatización.
Y no se confundan, son muchos trabajos.
Probablemente sean la mitad de los empleos de la economía.
Pero luego, al otro lado de la línea,
tenemos todos los trabajos que requieren algún tipo de habilidad
que percibimos como exclusivamente humana,
y estos son los empleos que creemos a salvo.
Basándome en lo que sé acerca del juego de go,
lo habría imaginado en el lado seguro de esta línea.
Pero el hecho de que no lo está y de que Google solucionó este problema
sugiere que esa línea va a ser muy dinámica.
Se va a desplazar de una forma
que barrerá trabajos que percibimos como a salvo de la automatización.
El otro aspecto clave que hay que entender
es que esto no atañe en absoluto solo a los trabajos manuales o de salario bajo,
o a los empleos y tareas
llevados a cabo por gente con nivel educativo bajo.
Hay mucha evidencia que indica
que estas tecnologías suben rápido por la escalera de las competencias.
Por lo tanto, ya vemos un impacto
en los trabajos profesionales,
las tareas ejecutadas por gente como contables,
analistas financieros, periodistas, abogados, radiólogos, etc.
Así que es probable que muchas de nuestras suposiciones
sobre el tipo de ocupaciones y tareas y empleos
que serán amenazados por la automatización sean desafiadas en el futuro.
Creo que estas tendencias revelan que es probable
que en el futuro acabemos teniendo un considerable desempleo.
O como mínimo
podríamos enfrentar mucho subempleo o estancamiento de los sueldos,
tal vez, incluso, bajas salariales.
Y, por supuesto, crecientes niveles de desigualdad.
Todo esto va a producir un alto nivel de estrés
en el tejido social.
Pero también existe un problema económico fundamental:
hoy en día los empleos son el mecanismo principal
que dispensa ingresos y, por consiguiente, poder adquisitivo
a los consumidores que compran los productos y servicios que producimos.
Para tener una economía de mercado vibrante
hay que tener muchos consumidores
que sean capaces de comprar los productos y los servicios
que se producen.
Si no los hay se corre el riesgo de un estancamiento económico,
incluso de una espiral económica descendente,
ya que no hay suficientes consumidores para comprar lo que producimos.
Es importante darse cuenta
de que todos nosotros, como individuos,
contamos con el acceso a esa economía de mercado para tener éxito.
Pueden visualizarlo pensando en una persona realmente excepcional.
Imaginen que toman a Steve Jobs
y lo sueltan en una isla desierta.
En esa isla correrá por todos lados recogiendo cocos,
como cualquier otra persona.
No va a ser nada especial porque no existe un mercado
donde pueda desplegar sus increíbles talentos.
Así que el acceso a este mercado es vital para los individuos
y también para el sistema entero para que sea sostenible.
Entonces la pregunta va a ser: ¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto?
Y pueden ver esto a través de un marco utópico.
Pueden imaginar un futuro donde todos trabajamos menos,
tenemos más tiempo para el ocio
más tiempo para pasar con nuestras familias,
para hacer cosas que consideramos auténticamente gratificantes, etc.
Y creo que esta es una magnífica visión.
Es algo que, sin duda, deberíamos esforzarnos para conseguir.
Pero al mismo tiempo creo que deberíamos ser realistas
y reconocer que es muy probable que enfrentemos un serio problema
de distribución de ingresos.
Es probable que mucha gente se quede atrás.
Y creo que para resolver ese problema tendremos que encontrar un modo
para disociar los ingresos del trabajo tradicional.
Y la forma mejor y más directa que conozco para hacerlo
es algún tipo de ingreso garantizado o Renta Básica Universal.
Esta se está convirtiendo en una idea muy importante.
Está ganando terreno y se están llevando a cabo muchos proyectos piloto
y experimentos importantes por todo el mundo.
Mi opinión personal es que la renta básica no es la panacea;
no es necesariamente una solución inmediata,
sino más bien un punto de partida.
Es una idea que nos puede servir como base para refinarla.
Por ejemplo, una cosa sobre la que he escrito mucho
es la posibilidad de incorporar incentivos explícitos a la renta básica.
Para ilustrarlo imaginen que son estudiantes sin dinero.
Imaginen que corren el riesgo de abandonar los estudios.
Y aun así, imaginen que saben que en algún momento futuro,
pase lo que pase,
recibirán la misma renta básica que todos los demás.
En mi opinión, eso se convierte en un incentivo malsano
para que se rindan y abandonen la escuela.
Así que no estructuremos las cosas de esa forma.
En su lugar, paguemos a la gente que acaba el colegio
algo más que a los que se limitan a dejarlo.
Y podemos tomar esa idea
de incentivos constructivos y quizás extenderla a otros ámbitos.
Por ejemplo, podríamos crear un incentivo para trabajar en la comunidad
y ayudar a los demás o para beneficiar al medio ambiente, etc.
Así que al incorporar incentivos a la renta básica podríamos mejorarla
y tal vez también dar por lo menos algunos pasos
para resolver otro problema
que creo que tendremos que enfrentar en el futuro
que es: ¿Cómo vamos a encontrar sentido y plenitud,
y cómo vamos a ocupar nuestro tiempo
en un mundo con menos demanda de trabajo tradicional?
Creo que ampliando y refinando la renta básica podemos mejorarla
y quizás también podamos contribuir
para que sea más aceptable y factible política y socialmente,
y así aumentar las probabilidades de que se haga realidad.
Creo que una de las objeciones básicas, casi instintiva,
que muchos tenemos ante la idea de la renta básica
o ante cualquier ampliación significativa del sistema de seguridad
es el miedo de acabar con demasiadas personas
subidas al carro económico sin las suficientes tirando de ese carro.
Aun así, lo que quiero dejar claro aquí es que en el futuro
las máquinas serán cada vez más capaces de tirar de ese carro.
Eso debería dejarnos más opciones
a la hora de estructurar nuestra sociedad y economía.
Creo que al final será más que una simple una opción,
será un imperativo.
El motivo, desde luego, es que todo esto va a someter
a nuestra sociedad a un alto nivel de estrés.
Y también porque los trabajos son el mecanismo que da a los consumidores
el poder adquisitivo para que impulsen la economía.
Si ese mecanismo falla en el futuro
tendremos que sustituirlo con otro o correr el riesgo
de que nuestro sistema deje de ser sostenible.
Pero la conclusión es que estoy convencido de que solucionar estos problemas
y encontrar la forma de construir una economía que funcione para todos,
a cada nivel de nuestra sociedad,
será uno de los mayores retos que enfrentaremos
en los próximos años y décadas.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)